Hello, I'm Jonathan Simon with
the Google Cloud Platform team.
I'm going to show you a demo of
using Compute Engine to set up
a simple Cloud based web server.
That way you can see the
process and then try it out
for yourself.
Let's get started by pointing
a browser to cloud.Google.com.
Click to My Console link to
view the developer's console.
Now that we're in the console,
we'll create a new project.
We're creating a
test web server,
so we'll call it
Web Server Project.
We'll also change the
suggested product ID.
Agree to the terms of service,
and then click Create.
That'll start the
project creation process.
Now, the project
that's being created
will have access to all
of Google's Cloud Platform
services.
Compute Engine is
a paid service,
so the first thing
we'll need to do
is set up our
billing information.
You'll likely be surprised at
how affordable experimenting
with Compute Engine can be.
After we've entered our
billing information,
we'll navigate to the
Compute Engine VM Instances
page, where we should see a
list of the virtual machines
that we've created.
We don't currently have
any, so let's add one.
Start by clicking the
Create Instance button.
We'll specify the name
as Test Web Server.
For the zone, we'll
create our instance
in US central1 F. For the
machine type, since this
is a test, we'll select the
smallest one available-- The F1
micro, with just over
half a gigabyte of memory.
And we'll go with the suggested
default image, which is debian.
Next, click the Allow
HTTP Traffic check
box, since this VM is
going to be a web server.
All the other settings should
be OK for our purposes,
so we can now click
the Create button
to create the virtual machine.
Note that because we went
with the default settings,
a 10 gigabyte persistent
disk will be created, named
Test Web Server.
That will be used as the
boot disk for the instance.
Persistent disks are
especially useful,
because they can live on beyond
a specific virtual machine's
lifetime.
This allows you to save the
state of your virtual machine
at any point in time,
and then restore it
at any time in the future.
Our instance is almost ready.
Some final health
checks are being
run, which is the last
step before the server is
ready to use.
There, now our instance
has been created.
In order to make changes,
like in selling software
on our Compute Engine
virtual machine,
we'll need to remotely
access the machine.
There's a quick way to do that
right from the Instance Details
page.
Next to the VM's details,
there's an SSH link.
Clicking that link
will open a new browser
tab that contains a secure
shell into the VM instance.
And there we go.
We've remotely accessed
our test web server.
Here we are at the command line.
Well, let's install
some software.
Specifically, some
web server software.
The web server software
we're going to install
is Apache Web Server.
A standard command used on Linux
to install software is apt get.
So we're going to type sudo to
run the command as super user,
apt get install Apache 2.
It's going to ask us to confirm
that we want to install it.
Hit Y, and press Enter.
The installation
process has started.
And now Apache has
been installed.
As part of the
installation process,
Apache creates a
default web page.
We can try loading
that default web
page in a browser to
confirm that we are actually
serving web pages.
Back in the
developer's console, we
can easily do this by
clicking the external IP
address of the VM instance.
And there we go.
The default Apache page.
Great, our test web server
is serving up web pages.
Now, to prove that
this is our web server,
let's modify the
default web page.
We'll jump back over to
our SSH tab, and type
the following command to
open up our default web
page in an editor.
We'll start by typing sudo, to
run the command as superuser,
nano, which is the
text editor we'll use,
and then the location
of the default web page,
which is var/www/index.html.
When we run that, it opens
the web page in an editor.
First, we'll remove the
default text that's there.
And then we'll paste in
an image so we can easily
tell that the page
has been modified.
We'll save the page
in nano by pressing
the Control key
and X, and then Y
and Enter to close
and save the file.
Back in the browser, we should
be able to refresh the page.
And there is our new
custom default web page.
Now, I would call
this test a success.
The final thing we need
to do to wrap up our test
is to delete the virtual
machine and the persistent disk.
As I do that, let's make
a calculation about how
much this whole test cost.
We'll select our
test web server,
and click the Delete
button to delete
the VM and its persistent disk.
Click the Delete button
again to confirm.
The deletion
process has started.
So, how much did it
cost to run this demo?
The current virtual machine
price for the type we used is
$0.80 per hour.
Compute Engine VM
instances are built
at a minimum of 10 minutes,
and we ran our server
for less than that.
So our virtual
machine usage cost
comes in at under
2/10 of one cent.
Their persistent disk pricing
is $0.04 per gigabyte per month.
So that comes to well under
a cent for the default 10
gigabyte boot disk that we used.
So everything we just
did on Compute Engine,
for less than one cent.
And there we go, the virtual
machine and its persistent disk
have been deleted.
Thanks for watching.
Now it's your turn.
Go try creating your own
cloud based web server
on Compute Engine.